so
so
um
this is an example of why guys say you
can't take a hoe into a housewife
because basically what she did was she
said she changed got the kids that she
wanted from Russell and then when she
got what she wanted she's doing this
[ __ ] again do you guys think that's
acceptable behavior from a wife I mean
she's a she's a dancer okay but
it depends on how much she said she's
changed because I don't know how much
she said she's she waited till she was
married with Russell oh [ __ ] well before
she started twerking no no to have sex
what yeah it hurt you didn't know that
well oh okay I'm sorry I left a piece of
this story yeah so so basically after
she dated the bad boy she said she'd
change she was a new person and she
decided yeah found God and women tend to
find God around like 27 to like 30s
early 30s because because it's in like
times running out so they need to base
it's a mating strategy so they need to
basically say I'm more pure than I
actually am and like yeah I'm a higher
value woman than I actually am basically
but she was a virgin no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no that's the point
so she she slept with all the rappers
and then made the next guy yeah okay and
then dear future she says she would
change didn't have sex with anybody and
then once she got wrestled then that's
when she went back and yeah so they
dated for a year didn't have sex they
got married and so she this is he's
thinking this is a Godly one it's the
same thing with Megan Good
I don't know
okay oh American actress yeah um but but
basically now
she got the they get they got the kids
they're a little bit older and now this
behavior is coming back 10 years later
basically
so she was already having the kids at
that time of the video
no this is now so she has three kids now
yes dated now basically yes and the the
and the argument is you can't marry a
hoe because she will always return to
the streets
I hear that um in terms of like the
twerking
I think I've given her a lot of leeway
because she's a dancer but if she
actually was like became born again and
she was just
full-on Christian wasn't doing anything
like that then yeah but in terms of her
career
you don't think you can she's a
performer you can't perform without
twerking on a car
yeah
do we all see the same video yeah what
I'm saying is this part of a brand so I
think it's similar to how you were
saying that um
um the whatever that young guy's name is
and how he was trapped by Britney
Renault yeah um suicide E.J Washington
yeah so like I don't know but I think I
think part of Kim K's brand is giving
glug look so what should she return to
Gibbon glug glug because that's how she
got famous oh
this is great that's a great analogy it
is an analogy
a great one that's good yeah I don't I
don't think it's that's their comment I
don't think I don't think it's
appropriate I don't think it's
appropriate behavior
I don't think it's appropriate behavior
but
I don't know I'm kind of excusing it I
wouldn't
um how many artists twerk but she like
she has yeah I'm not disregarding that
she's a dancer I I grew up listening to
Sierra grew up seeing her loved her
music videos but there's a way like you
are portraying yourself in this way
you're portraying yourself at this as
this wife this sensual wife with the
family and everything and then what
there's there's no context of
choreography there's no context of a
song being written there's no context of
that to be able to do that it's just hey
I got these dancers we're gonna go twerk
on a car at a gas station I think that's
not a song I think it's because I never
saw her as whatever she rebranded
herself as I think that's oh Sierra yeah
I think that might be why yeah that's
the thing she's claiming to be brand new
she's just like no sex before marriage
I'm a Christian now then now you do
Madness yeah that's yeah I guess she was
doing that if she posted a video and she
was twerking on Russell I'd be like go
hey girl that's your man like go ahead
do that but now it's out of the context
of but when it's just her it's not okay
it it sends like a mixed signal because
if it's just imagine if it if you and
your girls got a car went to the petrol
station it was like we're going to twerk
real quick and then your daughter
friends sitting around squirrel
scrolling inside yeah and they're like
is this your mom it's like yeah that's
my mom why is she twerking at a petrol
station on a car it's just it's
difficult because now she's in a setting
to where that not only affects it's not
her anymore it's not her image it
affects her kids it affects Russell's
image now that she is doing that and
exposing herself
and do you think that she wouldn't have
discussed it with him before do you
think she just did this and maybe she
doesn't feel like she needs to she did
this and he had no maybe she doesn't
feel like I think Russell's a simp and I
think I think a lot of guys have been so
conditioned that they don't even know
what they want so you think it should be
a man a woman expresses her sexuality
only in relation into her man and if
it's I think her on her own even though
he's as you said a one percent man it is
not okay unless he's there
I I what do you mean by expressing her
sexuality perhaps she likes twerking
perhaps it makes her feel good perhaps
it's something that when she sees
herself she's like
chicken
I think it's provocative it's something
that's gonna generate her more income
it's gonna get people talking about it
so so if I have kids and I want to start
only fans because it generates more
income do you think that's a good
representation of my kids and my husband
I was on a Hindu recently
um
no no it's not that bad
um and uh one of the girls I just met
her on the handy I've never met her
before she was actually a virgin when
she got married and she said her boss
she had I think it's a bell I don't know
do you have any fans anymore
like a a bachelorette okay yeah
uh so yeah we're on a bachelorette and
she said she heard her boss
a bell went off on his phone she was
like I've heard that sound before
where's that from
she'd heard it on Tick Tock it's from
only fans turns out him and his wife
have a BDSM only fans they're married
with kids do you think that's an optimal
environment for kids to grow up in with
um basically anyone can pay ten dollars
and see their parents having sex because
if you come here if you went to my
school your mum's breast is going around
all demanding facts
maybe not optimal but
what effect do you think that will have
do you think it's just going to become
the norm do you think I hope I think I
hope not all my mates bashing over my
mom's breasts like no no what if they
did it anyway without a picture
but that's not the same okay it's deaf
advertisement because at the end of the
day it's it's selfish because you're
putting you above your kid you're
putting like one in Quick Cash because
that's another way women are bailed out
right if a man doesn't have a job he's
just homeless
if a woman doesn't want to work she can
go on only fans and make six figures
yeah and so it's it's
you can't really feel bad for those
girls either and say oh you're forced to
be sexualized because yeah no it's good
because but a lot of a lot of those
girls will say that and then come in
after Mia Khalifa
right and then come back and and what's
the other